je vais charger les filets
l'iodure épicé était loin de réussir
visite rigola
processus carrés de l'Union européenne
lithographies version décaféinée du principe
directeur du modem du matin, Dima peint Vladlen
aller à la science en Russie hiksu minsyan
ils sont ukrainiens, ils ne volent pas
comprendre et nous sommes brûlés et analogues nucléaires
a pris vie 2 Russie timidité avec de la glace et ça
il n'y a pas de colle de différentes espèces de vie parmi toutes
l'été on ne peut pas le réparer en douceur le lithium est très
ils le rendront, conneries de quelque chose, on va le jeter
complètement et/ou liquide est celui qu'ils connaissent
Mots tordus russes, jambes des régimes et
le coffre lui-même oh c'est cool, chérie, comment
meilleure équipe la vôtre, vous avez 0 ou 1 bouton
Galich a fait briller tout mon livre et l'a donné à mon fils
nurbana à partir de tampons de coton de zéro, puis elle a même
faiblement c'est la discipline et saisir et diviser
pas de typhus logique et
trempe par division livrée effectuée par
des chiffres et confortable pour soi
sommet du pommier complété vision ukraine jouant
pour les messages et ainsi de suite
puis on commence à prendre du volume, c'est trop tard
Je vais les trouver, m'asseoir et
on accepte eh bien
oui, Sandisk Ladu nomme les historiens
aile cassée, il est là, en route, Natali, oui, toi
laissé plié tu lui as juré un nouveau
la lumière a besoin de genre
La Fédération de Russie rencontre Andersen
pourra alibi hôtel maison h berline - danse
avec ces champs universels américains et
la pousada est un universel
[musique]